let's grind up a game here ladies and
gents
okay so we are playing
the black pieces let's play sicilian
defense ivory liberty thank you for the
brand let's play cecilia on defense
[Music]
and what should we do how what sicilian
should we play
um i don't know
let's play hmm
i don't know let's play d6
okay he's gone bishop c4 so mercifully
we don't have to uh
choose now we've faced this move before
many many times and we already know how
to react to it
and the way we react to it is not to do
anything special we just need to develop
our pieces normally
uh i like to start with knight c6 it's
very flexible
i like we don't need to play e6
immediately there's no immediate danger
to the f7 pawn
uh since we've already played d6 okay so
now there is a danger to the f7 pawn but
now the movie 6 makes more sense
because it opens up the attack on the
knight e6
now he's the type of player probably to
go queen h5
queen f3 and well i know what you guys
are thinking
i don't really see 1400s play like this
very often
um what do we do
whoa guys look carefully look carefully
everybody no you're trusting you're
trusting this is classic trusting
people are thinking knight e5 the knight
on g5 is hanging
he never defended it right
so and now do we move our queen back
do we oh no we don't this guy has
had better days in his chest career i
think
okay we're going to keep taking stuff
queen takes b2
wow that's ridiculous another one
we could have taken the knight too but
let's evacuate our queen simultaneously
and not much to comment here he finally
castles we're gonna develop our night
well it's in indonesia it's different
time i think but okay
whoa erica nogo with a five gifted
girl thank you ericanogo for the five
really appreciate it guys how is the
1400 making these errors i don't know i
mean this guy
we're just gonna keep developing this
guy
that was weird i mean that's that's
uncharacteristic opening play by 1400
for sure
and liquescence with a prime so we're
just developing our pieces here no need
to
reinvent the wheel castles and then
we're going to probably open up the
center we're up two pieces and two pawns
all we need to do is complete our
development rook fe1
doesn't change the fact that we should
castle
100 bids for cinnamon salsa yeah so this
is what he was preparing now if we want
to play five head
if we want to play five fed the move
queen c3 is what i think
most of you guys would play that would
be fun
is there a five-head idea and how do i
see this idea again this is this concept
of no
pattern recognition whenever there's a
bishop on c4 in the sicilian
as we've seen from my lessons with
charlie where i was showing him lines
like this
you have to constantly be looking for
ideas that involve
getting a piece onto e4 either through a
sacrifice usually the move is knight
takes c4
but this is a variety of that and then
peace lands on e4 we go d5
winning back the peace with interest
because this bishop is generally
important
here we have to take with a queen
because the queen is hanging thank you
mukimic for the six knight takes
and the reason we embark on this whole
uh expedition is because we want to
trade pieces we're up two pieces
so this simply simplifies the position
and uh wins the game essentially on the
spot thank you hk bkh for the 12 and
bubbas
can't even keep up with the subs it was
important to establish by the way
that this bishop on e7 is protected by
the knight i did notice this
as i was calculating all right let's get
our let's get our last uh
undeveloped piece out and hit the pawn
let's get our other bishop to f6 and hit
the pawn again
now there's many ways of winning this
position we're up
a million pieces so it really doesn't
matter as i always like to say
the traditional plan is to make a passed
pawn and push it
uh couldn't be simpler but in this
situation we have some open files so we
could
perhaps offer up some trades in order to
ease that process
what would be a good solid move in this
position here thank you
locomotive double07 yeah why don't we go
rook fv8
i would totally make some luft too
it's weird to talk about these things
now totally let's take the rook
and take the pawn we don't have to make
lift as long as you can
you know you can see that there's a rook
on a8 gotta gotta make sure you're not
hallucinating or you'll get checkmated
thank you cinnamon slicer for the
hundred
now we've cleared the path for the
d-pawn the game is over
yeah very simple stuff here
now one good way of paving the way for
the pawn rolling out the red carpet
where should we put our bishop
where should we put our bishop
yeah so bishop c2 is great and then d3
you guys have seen this idea before
right
very elegantly the bishops are covering
both
subsequent squares the only thing that
remains is to get the knight out of the
picture
so that he's not able to give his knight
up for the pawn or something to that
effect
and we can do that by of course playing
the move knight to d4
offering up the nitrate which is good
independently but also paves the okay
he's going to simply blunder the knight
uh and yeah this is a very one-sided
game i don't know what
got into this guy but is what it is guys
yeah we'll play another one obviously
now
okay so knight c6925 e6 right
this is where when your opponent plays
like this as curious with a five
damn girl thank you curious for the five
gifted subs man the support has been
unreal today
thank you ladies and gentlemen i really
appreciate it
okay so
when your opponent plays in this way you
you just don't want to trust them
right you want to you want to be very
critically engaged to the position
because you never know
what kind of bluffs they're going to try
to pull on you now how would you respond
to the move queen h5 here i want you
guys to tell me
what would be the best way to respond to
this cinnamon slicer with the tier one
now what you should notice here is that
the knight on g5 is a tier two
undefended piece
and it's defended only by the queen
which is easy to kick away we go g6
no matter where the queen goes there's
going to be a fork or a pin
that displaces the queen and severs the
connection with the knight so queen g4
for instance 95 is a fork and
if queen h4 then we go bishop e7
followed by h6
right so this kind of stuff it never
flies
all right the rest is very simple i'm
not even commenting we just take all the
spawns and win the game
let's get one more game in everybody
ready any questions on this
before we get to the next game
uh so this was a bishop c4 sicily now
technically
i've heard this referred to as the
udacity sicilian
uh named after grand master russian
israeli grandmaster michael
i think it's mikhail you dawson
and the udacian sicilian is usually
played with the move d3 followed by
c3 and and then sometimes the queen
comes out to be three but
knight g5 is where uh i think the theory
ends
so in any case uh
on to the next one would it have been
worse to capture the knight rather than
the queen
oh no knight takes would have been fine
it doesn't really matter i just wanted
to extricate the queen preemptively
just so it doesn't get tangled up
doesn't matter we're up a million pieces
let's move on the bowdler attack okay
so let's play e4 thank you where the
chosen quants for the tier one
and he goes knight c6 the nimzovich
defense
as you guys know min actually likes to
play this move
and this is what i would call a
transpositional opening
large bloops with five it has a very
high probability of transposing
into another opening it there it has its
own theory
but it often transposes and white has
two fundamental moves thank you
large bloops white can play d4
and that's the more independent move
because
black often responds with e5 or d5
that's the traditional nimzovich opening
but
i propose it that it's much simpler here
to play what other move that encourages
a transposition into a rye lopez or
italian
what other move seems natural here
if you play the vienna you can play
knight c3
if you play the rylopas or the italian
you can play knight f3
and the only way to keep the
independence of the line is to play d5
if he plays this we'll talk about it he
goes g6 just like min
it's actually yeah it's not bad knight
c6 is not a bad move it's not refutable
directly or anything of that sort
now it's time to play what move should
we play bishop b5 should we play like
we're playing a rye lopez
no right we shouldn't because he didn't
play e5 so now there's no need
not to play d4 okay
so yeah this is mid so a lot of you guys
probably are tempted to play d5
which is not bad and i've played it
against min but then i can slide into e5
or it can even drop back to ba
the bottom line here is that white often
bites off more than he can chew
right we often advance all these pawns
and then we find that black starts
attacking them just like in the hyper
modern opening
so what other alternatives exist here
well we can simply develop the knight to
c3
but one very measured positional move
that i like in the
russian school of chess spirit biting on
granite how do we make sure of that some
of you are proposing this move c3
let's make the the two pieces bite on
granite
now what about the knight you might ask
what about what do we do with the name
well then i could later go on to d2
and watch as i orchestrate a scheme of
development
that's very common in the games of
gotokamsky for example he plays this
against the perk and the modern
this bishop on f1 it goes to d3
and it goes to d3 in order to lend
further support to the e4 pawn
we're going to develop our pieces in a
way such that we are
we are keeping massive
control over our center while developing
in a relatively active way so let's go
bishop to d3
kind of like in the london you guys see
how this bishop is sort of
developed in the shadow of these pawns
these pawns act as
body guards to the bishop stopping night
before stopping knight e5
i kind of like this way of developing
now we castle
right star polemic well i overused that
phrase
now this bishop on c1 where do you guys
think it should go
where do you guys think it should go
should it go to e3 to defend the pawn
no i'm tricking you guys we don't need
to go to e3 because that is the function
served by the c3 pawn the c3 pawn
is giving enough support to d4 we just
don't have the equivalent here so that's
why we got the bishop there
now let's consider bishop f4 for a
second looks good
but it falls right into the move e5 with
tempo
black can play rookie eight or something
and then go e5 the tempo
which i don't want to encourage and so
that leaves the g5 square
right so
a6 and final link in the chain
this b1 knight well it needs to go out
let's go knight b to d2 we're not afraid
of him going b5
it's not particularly scary in fact it
weakens
his position a little bit it weakens the
night and stuff
and now we need to continue making
improvements to our position bringing
pieces into the game
and preparing some sort of a central
pawn break which
would be premature at the moment it
would be premature at the moment
because if we were to play e5 he would
no he would not do that he would take on
e5
and if you look at this bishop on d3 it
might end up being hanging let's go
rookie one
very nice you guys have a good sense of
this position i like it
all right and we don't need to play a
three we're not afraid of b4
and the reason why is because we have a
pawn chain
b4 doesn't threaten anything and to the
contrary it actually weakens
more of the queen side right queen a4
and stuff becomes possible
that a6 spawn becomes weak right it's
it just black doesn't have enough uh
firepower really on the queen side to
get anything done that's part of the
appeal of building this kind of pawn
chain is we can just
it's very very solid we don't need to
keep maintaining it right
it's like a move-in ready house you
don't need to you don't need to invite
the remodelers
everything's in place just turn key
okay knight f1i23 is a phenomenal idea
that's a
very typical continuation in such
positions
okay so
let's think about what to do and in fact
i love the move knight f1 here
get the knight to g3 accumulate pieces
on the king side
uh does that make sense much like in the
rye lopez let's go knight f1
yeah his knights are sort of dangling
around
okay so that's a very ugly looking move
now where should we put our bishop well
let's think about it for a second
bishop h4 is one candidate move we can
also keep the bishop on this diagonal
but let's try to understand where we
want our bishop to be
given where we want our other pieces to
be
right and that's a good way to think
about it now where is this night
probably going to go
well as i said we want to go to g3 right
could you guys identify the problem with
putting the bishop on h4
in that regard what's the issue there
right it would potentially fall into a
g5 trap
so let's drop the bishop back to e3 not
because we need to protect the punch but
just because it's a good square
now we can complete the maneuver and
we can later perhaps go queen d2 and
bishop h6 that would be another good
idea
to further soften up black's king's now
we might not be playing the most
ambitious way
i think there were probably better ways
to to target black's position
but i'm just trying to showcase the
typical setup here
and how solid it is now let's start
adding a little bit of heat
to the position there's many ways to
approach this we can go on the king side
we can go on the queen side
but one risk-free way to apply pressure
if you play the rye lopez
you should be familiar with this idea
black often has a pawn on b5 it sticks
out like a sore thumb
what can we do with that pawn how can we
pressure it
and also try to open up some files for
our rook
what move comes to mind this is super
typical concept
a4 beautiful now
you might look at this for a second and
say why is that a dangerous thing well
first of all we're threatening to
capture the pawn second of all if black
takes on a4 we take with our queen
and black's position begins to collapse
and now he goes knight c4 and panics
first thing i see is that the rooks are
in a standoff thank you
to dirk so the move a takes b5 must be
calculated
but what happens after knight takes b2
which is i'm pretty sure what he has in
mind
well if you look carefully when the
moment that he played f6
and this is where observation comes in
the moment that he played f6 you should
have said
you should have made a mental note to
yourself ah i have a check on b3
this is the moment when i noticed that
so if you are already primed
to see that well it shouldn't be hard to
spot if he takes b3
if he plays knight takes e3 i like
taking with the f pawn in order to open
up the f file
where we might light her attack and beef
up uh our
our central bonds he should take on e3
he should take on e3 that's his only
move
i hope everything making sense so far
yeah he does i mean this guy is good
he's competent
and now we're threatening to win another
pawn so he's probably going to go a5
nope he's going to blunder another pawn
well there was nothing he could have
done because a5 would have met with b4
and yeah that's why you never play f6
this is the result of playing f6
we're up two pawns we have a knife on fc
on a6 here and our center remains as
solid as ever
okay no no it's not that f takes
is is a crazy tactical move it's
actually positional i would say
now how are we going to
improve our position here what are we
going to do we go to c5
well there's multiple ways to approach
this d5 is
very possible we could try to lock the
position up
and in fact i quite like that idea
locking the position up here is a good
idea because
it appears to me likely that we're going
to
maybe push the beep on at some point and
try to make something of our double
passers
but on the other hand d5 does leave our
bishop
very very passive right it leaves our
bishop
blocked by a bunch of our own pawns
there's really no necessity why did we
do all of this
if now we're going to close up the
center so
many good moves here let's play very
directly
we can play b4 bishop c4 is a great move
although it does walk into knight b6
rook f1 is good repositioning the rook
but you know what move i like it's not
bishop c4
because that walks into knight b6 with
tempo what's a move that has a similar
idea
but doesn't fall under the crosshairs of
the knight
so it's a hard it's a tricky move guys
it's a bishop move
bishop b5 i'm going to play the move
because we're low on time bishop b5
this is one of those moves which it's
hard to pinpoint exactly what it does
but one of the things that it does
is builds a battery queen a4 hitting the
knight
and preparing a7 if knight b8 we go a7
and the knight is trapped that's the
specific line i calculated there
so it just puts pressure on the opponent
it's hard to always quantify what those
moves accomplished but he has a very
five head idea here
which i missed let's see if he finds it
and then we have an even more five head
response
the five head idea is to go knight a6
beat
bishop takes a6 rook takes a seven
winning back the bishop and winning that
past pawn
i miss that but that's pretty five fed
right well that was one head by me
i should have seen that
oh yeah i need to
improve my camera angle i might switch
to my desktop for
for the uh russian stream
all right i stream from a laptop right
now now he doesn't see it
now wait a minute a takes b8 can't he
take our queen
well no right because a takes b8 we make
a queen
so the funny thing is we can probably
get away with taking
because he i don't think he sees knight
knight a6 but
we're gonna try to play objectively here
so we win a piece he has to play rook
takes b8
and then we have a little bit of an
issue to deal with our bishop is hanging
and we have a bunch of pawns that are
hanging
we just need to solidify everything we
need to glue things together
let's glue things together preferably
tying down
the rook and the queen what move comes
to mind in that regard
yeah the move c4 comes to mind it's kind
of a glue move
and we have a very five head move in
response to t takes e3
i feel like i've overused that rather
than just
passively moving the king aside we can
go directly at the source of the problem
which is the queen well we can think
about queen a5 but
let's find the best execution for that
queen a7
now i'm gonna have to play a little bit
faster because i don't i certainly don't
want to lose on time
i have to say this guy is
resilient he's he's a good player this
has not been an easy game
but now he starts to fall apart as we uh
grab this pawn
and we're up a full piece with total
domination over his pieces
but let's not relax f4 is a threat
forking the rook and the knight
now you can defend against forks by
moving one of the pieces involved
moving the knight seems very passive
okay does the rook have any homes well
if we move the rope doesn't that blow
under the pawn nope because the knight
defends it
where can we move the rook where where
can we move it so that it does something
it covers the diagonal yeah the x-ray
exactly
we can go rick a3 to stack the rooks but
let's look at the other weaknesses ah
we have a weak pawn on d6 left attack it
right so i'm looking around the board
what can the rook do
rook d3 simple straightforward logic
okay
and look at the pawn on c4 gluing the
bishop this is why i always say
pawns are the best defenders because
they're so permanent
we don't have to worry about the bishop
again
always piss chinese
three yeah good one good one
rook takes d6 rick d7 is coming in the
game is basically over
okay so
the idea here
is also to go h3 potentially and kill
the bishop
all right so does he want h4 he doesn't
really want h4
we can go h3 here we don't even have to
rush taking the pawn i i have a bit of a
uneasy sense that he might do something
on the other hand let's just take i
don't think he has anything
if he goes h4 we take it with a knight
and then that very same knight will go
to g6 and crush
but if you felt unsafe or uneasy you
could go h3
and attack the bishop here it was
important to establish that the knight
covered that square and that's it is
coming
boom goes the dynamite and now we start
taking stuff
this is the fun part ladies and
gentlemen this is the fun part
we could have also taken with a rook on
g6 forking his two bishops
okay let's grab this guy
and now one minute plenty of time
he played very well no this was not an
easy game okay so how do we approach
this kind of position the simplest would
be to go knight takes e4
but if we look very carefully in such
situations
undefended pieces are crucial and as
lono points out this is a very typical
fork rook g6
boom boom game over
right so you're always looking for and i
can't help it you're always looking for
these tactical observations trying to
always get a leg up on your opponent
and well we can take any bishop with
either rook
don't don't let this pawn through stop
the pawn with the king right
the russian stream is beckoning
it's beckoning
maiden one oh oh made in one yeah i did
have minute one i missed it
i didn't see the bishop i forgot about
it it was so glued together
that uh i forgot about it but let's do
it now
yeah it's mate i forgot that the bishop
was covering the square
law okay
and i tried to you know
this is your uh resident 3000 ladies and
gentlemen missing men in ones
so knight c6
right the alakin is knight f6
this is a completely different opening
and it definitely is underrated
now d4 is the principled
way to meet it and now black has d5
this is a line i find to be incredibly
annoying
for white i don't like playing this
because this is like a form of the
scandinavian where black often quickly
castles long there's a lot of theory
here
white's supposed to be better but i
never know how to play and but why can
get crushed why can literally get
crushed here i have gotten crushed
in this kind of line because this pawn
is under fire e5 is coming
not a good line to play in blitz
and another move for black is to play e5
this one is i think a little bit more
innocuous but i can just take on e5 or y
can go d5
but even this kind of close center
position the knight reroutes to g6
it can be hard to play this with white
and so i would not give people what they
want
yeah exactly i think black players you
know they like
these positions that's why i play knight
f3 if they go d5 here
well you can take it go knight c3 and
there's still a lot of theory here but
you don't have to go d4 you can go
bishop b5 and emphasize peace
development
all right so you can look up the theory
here you don't need me to tell you the
theories you can look it up
but this is a very dangerous move and
you shouldn't take it lightly in my
opinion all right g6
so g64 and g6 is possible there's
nothing wrong with this i think this guy
took a page out of men's book
we go c3 well we're doing a 6 000 sub
celebration
which is which is uh which is solid
which is definitely solid
now c3 makes sense to everybody right
biting on granite
uh now the bishop has been the you know
the sting has been taken out of the
bishop
so d6 bishop d3 protecting the center
i think our opening development was very
straightforward bishop g5 now again
bishop f4 walks essentially right into
e5 with tempo so for instance bishop g4
would be a good way to to preface this
and for example h3 bishop takes f3 and
there comes e5 with tempo
we don't want to invite them with tempo
so we want to go bishop g5
just to in fact it's the opposite right
we're discouraging e5 because that would
open up a pin
now if h6 then uh
i would recommend simply dropping to h4
sometimes in this line g5 bishop g3
happens black can go after the bishop
but notice that he's
really really weak in the king in doing
so
uh so this is a price we are willing to
pay
all right yeah castling queenside can be
possible
but i i like the setup a lot knight bd2
what i want you guys to understand is
that a lot of people automatically go a4
in such a position
to stop b5 and a4 is fine but not all
quote-unquote threats need to be stopped
in fact b5
i think is a is a positional mistake
because
there's just yeah you definitely sack on
g5 in such positions uh
no definitely this would be something i
would consider although maybe premature
i mean e5 i don't think white has enough
firepower
but you should definitely consider it
now i will say
yeah b5 is a positional mistake because
because there's simply um you know
the fact that black plays this alone
doesn't mean anything if that makes
sense and to the contrary black will
later have to deal with this weakness uh
after we played a4
right unnecessary prophylaxis
prophylaxis is great but only when it's
you know what it's necessary thank you
for the tier one rookie one knight d7
knight f1
transferring the knight bishop to e3
you know importantly ah
oh my lance
oh my lands what the
frick is that as champ with the
50 damn girl
oh my lance that's unbelievable champ
with a
50 tier one subs to the community with a
legendary donor out there
wowza
well that's our own little celebration
in here
my lanes girl yeah
well i will be after some of these uh
some of the uh some more of these
donors you're a dude dude
well damn girl is just
thank you prophet thank you thank you
champ i really appreciate it
that's uh amazing
absolutely amazing thanks for all your
support
okay yeah in response to every no no
f6 bishop b3 so before i was rudely
interrupted if anybody else wants to
rudely interrupt me
with uh with 50 subs
i will probably allow it yeah it's
become sort of an exclamation at this
point
if anybody wants to rudely interrupt i
will allow it
although i don't love it
thank you champ i really appreciate that
fantastic stuff
so back to the game um
bishop h4 just to recap
you know the problem is that he's going
to play g5
and the bishop is going to get trapped
which is why
we go bishop b3 and one piece of advice
that i have to share
and i say the same thing when you're
deciding which rook to put on a square
look at your other rooks look at your
other pieces the way that
you know it's like a sudoku puzzle you
know where some of the pieces belong you
may not know where the others belong
where the others belong can be a direct
product of where
you know you have to take the stuff that
you do know apply it and that
tells you stuff uh about the pieces
which you aren't sure where to put if
that makes sense and this is a good
application of that
okay so e5 knight g3 knight a5
and now comes a4 striking on the queen
side
striking right where it hurts that pawn
on b5
sticking out and making black regret it
now if black had tried to support the
pawn of c6 we would have of course taken
it
and either b4 wins the knight simply
or after c takes b5 we can play b4 and
even
take the pawn so this is just bad for
black he should have
i don't even know what black can do here
honestly he should probably just go
bishop b7 and lose the pawn
but knight c4 we play eight takes b5
this wins the knight now we're winning a
pawn we win another one
now this move bishop b5 right how did i
find this move
in a certain sense i think my brain
is automatically tuned to look at the
drawbacks of every move
to move c5 i notice that it weakens the
complex of light squares
around the queen side that should make
sense to everybody
and so the first move i thought of is
bishop c4 this guy bobbles he
recommended this
but then i saw ah he has knight b6
attacking the bishop and covering the
square
so do we have another way to do the same
thing yeah we kind of do bishop b5 maybe
go to c6 later not immediately
because he's we're going to lose the
pawn and then i see ah well we also have
queen a4
okay so queen b6 yeah it's sort of a
russian now it's not the best move given
that i missed the tactic but the
logic behind it is still instructive i
think so knight b8
a7 and here he missed a golden
opportunity
to go knight a6 and i'm sure we probably
have some sort of a win here
uh but the point is bishop a6 or k7 and
the bishop is
toast regardless of what we do
so in this position we wouldn't take on
a6 we'd find something else to do
maybe queen a5 maybe something to that
effect well thanks
oh another 5-head move could be knight
d2 knight c4 sort of benoni style
lifting the knight in
anyways one of these things would have
would have definitely been good
he takes we take we go c4 glue and
gluing in the bishop
now how did i sequin a7 as some of you
were indicating
uh what i don't like about the situation
is the
x-ray that the queen exerts over the
king
and i want to deal with this you can
deal with this from two different angles
sometimes people only uh i like to think
of this as targeting the symptoms versus
targeting the cause
you know if you the the taking the
tylenol move is king h1 you target the
symptoms but this construction is still
a little bit nasty
think about to always ask yourself can i
target the cause instead of the symptoms
the cause being the queen on b6 and its
control over the spawn
when you ask yourself that question
queen a7 is far likelier
to be found thank you star he takes it
now black had one last chance here to
complicate the game
does anybody see what it is if you were
playing black here wanted to complicate
the game
there's one last thing that black can do
here what is it
think about how to defend this pawn
tactically
how can black defend this pawn but in a
tactical way the move isn't very good
f5 is absolutely right but i don't know
that means correct in russian f5 and a
fur key three then f4 forks
bishop goddammit i can't try ours forks
the rook and the knight
what would white have done in response
to this i mean doesn't really matter
we can go knight g5 trying to stick the
knight into f7
and we we aren't afraid of this because
our pieces lend perfect
perfectly fine support uh f3 will never
happen because of the g pawn
so white is winning here but that would
have been perhaps the last
uh chance to to complicate things once
he loses the bond against over
any questions ladies and gentlemen any
[Music]
questions
you